[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT: Welcome, Joel.
JOEL GAMORAN: Thank you, Scott.
Thanks, guys.
I'm so excited to be here.
I've heard like-- there's
all this lore, when you don't
work at Google, about Google.
Like what's the campus like,
what are the people like?
And I'm kind of blown away.
It's really amazing.
And I have a total
nervousness just going
to college and stuff,
being in a group,
and a teacher calling on you.
So I won't call on you, but
I will ask for volunteers
because it's more fun to cook
with someone and not alone.
A little bit about
how I got started.
So at Sur la Table,
we teach classes
across the country
in 85 locations.
And I was in a class, and I
was looking in someone's trash
bowl.
And it was overfilled
with, like,
shrimp shells, cucumber
seeds, all these things
that, as a chef,
you're taught to save.
In the restaurant
industry there's
almost no profit margin,
literally very difficult.
So every ingredient
can make you money,
and you are taught
to not throw it away.
But as home cooks, we were
never really taught that.
I mean, raise your
hand if you guys have
like a grandma or a grandpa
or a great grandma and grandpa
who saved everything.
Raise your hand.
Most of us, right?
Sorry.
I'm loud already.
But most of us have that.
So we have this skill, maybe
from the Depression time,
where we saved everything.
But now, because food is
so easy and so accessible,
we kind of lost that.
And I realized that
and realize that we're
throwing away like $1,500
each every year in food waste.
It adds up to
about $119 billion.
Food waste is the
number one cause
right now to global warming.
It is the number one thing in
our dumps and in our landfills.
So when you dug into
this, it kind of was nuts.
And so I teamed up
with Katie Couric.
She's the executive
producer of the show.
Has anyone seen the show?
yeah?
Couple people?
Yeah, OK.
The show is me in my van.
This is Pippi, the red van.
Her name is Pippi
because she's red
and she has freckles
like Pippi Longstocking.
But Pippi was a piece of trash.
She was in a farm for like 50
years untouched, scrap metal.
And we turned her
into a kitchen,
and we drove her
across the country.
And each episode-- it's on A&E--
I meet up with different chefs
and we put on this amazing meal
for locals, shocking them
that the food on their plate
was food that we'd
normally see as trash.
So that's what
the show is about.
And Pippi represents
the movement,
represents this
idea that there's
so much potential
in these ingredients
that we're throwing away, right?
Like this is carrot tops.
I'm calling it right now,
parsley of 2019 right here.
This is the next hot herb.
You're going to see
this all the time.
And it's been around forever.
So I hope you guys get
a little inspired today.
We're going to whip
up a couple of recipes
starting with Pappa Pomodoro.
What the heck is that?
Anyone know?
Pappa Pomodoro.
No one knows?
OK.
So what did you say?
AUDIENCE: Pomodoro's tomato.
JOEL GAMORAN: You
go tomatoes, baby.
I love it.
Pappa, in this idea,
is a bread soup.
Super humble recipe
using really stale bread.
Who's thrown away
stale bread before?
I know.
It's like Scraps
Anonymous today.
OK, we all have
thrown away stuff.
So stale bread is absolutely
delicious you can make things
like bread crumbs with it.
There's amazing things.
For this recipe, it
thickens the soup
and almost gives it
this creamy texture that
is so addictive, so incredible.
So we're going to whip this up.
Who is willing to come cook
with me on this recipe?
Yes, come on up.
Come on up.
Yeah, give it up.
Oh, yeah, we'll start with you.
What's your name?
BRIA: Bria.
JOEL GAMORAN: Give
it up for Bria.
Takes guts coming up
here to cook with me.
OK.
So we've got a medium high pan,
or a pan on medium high heat.
So like out of 10,
this is like a six.
Cool?
So we're going to cut up
some garlic and some chili.
And I've got a
cool trick for you.
What's the spicy part
of a chili, Bria?
BRIA: The seeds.
JOEL GAMORAN: The seeds.
So if you grab a chile-- and
feel free to stand around here.
I'm cash.
So if you guys can't
see, let me know.
But you can take your
chile and roll it like this
and cut off the
bottom, and shake.
This one doesn't have a lot.
That's good.
This will be a non-spicy one.
But all the seeds will come out.
So if you roll them, it kind
of loosens it up, right?
So why don't you try?
Roll this guy, give it a shot.
Now while you're doing that,
I've got some olive oil.
And we've got tons of tomatoes.
Now on the tomatoes, they
come with their tops.
We all throw this away.
Smell this, Bria.
It smells like the farm.
Like it smells like
a fresh tomato.
These tops are unbelievable
infused in what you're cooking.
You can make butter with
these tops, like melt butter,
put the tops in and
take them out later,
and you have this tomato
butter that's unbelievable.
You can soak them in
teas, in your gazpachos.
But today we're going
to kind of use them
as like a flavor boost,
like a bomb in this, Cool?
So we've got some
chili, and the way
we're going to
chop this is we're
just going to slice it thin.
90% of people--
Bria, show me how you
hold the knife at home.
Yes.
You're all laughing.
You know you hold it wrong.
Show me.
How would you chop that?
OK.
No more.
I want you to keep
all your digits.
Yes.
So most people hold
their knife like Bria
did, and it's totally cool.
Some people do this.
Anyone do this?
My mom does this
with the finger.
I don't know what
the finger's about.
But the right way to hold your
knife is to pinch the blade
and wrap your fingers
around the bottom.
It feels horrible
for like three weeks.
But then you get used to it, and
you have so much more leverage,
you have so much more
power, so much more control.
And your knife cuts
will be more even,
which is really important
in cooking so everything
cooks at the same time.
Cool?
So I'll let you chop
up that other chile.
Go for it.
Yeah, just kind
of pinch the top.
Yeah, just kind of pinch it
and tuck your fingers back.
There you go.
Yeah, perfect.
All right.
So you got chile.
I got a little bit of olive oil.
I'm going to put it in the
pan, enough to kind of coat.
Cool.
And then I've got some garlic.
And in Italy they
slice their garlic.
It's more like this as
opposed to chopping it fine
or using the garlic press.
So slicing it is kind
of like a kiss of garlic
instead of like a
huge kind of mouth
full of it, which is
nice if you actually
are going to kiss someone
after this recipe.
So it's kind of more of a touch.
All right.
So we've got our chiles,
we've got our garlic.
Now what I'll have you do,
Bria, is grab all these things.
Do we have a bench
scraper in the house?
I totally forgot to ask for it.
Cool.
We're going to go like this.
And then you're going to
add all of these ingredients
to that oil.
Thank you.
By the way, if you
don't have one of these,
get one because everyone
uses their knife
and scoops up their ingredients,
and your knives go dull.
This saves your knife.
It's also good for
smashing garlic, chopping
dough, all that stuff.
So if you want a scoop that
up right into the hot oil.
Are you guys with me so far?
Are we having fun?
We're learning.
You guys are about to smell
some beautifulness right now.
Awesome.
So we've got garlic, we've
got a little bit of chile.
Everyone in the pool.
And then I've got some onion.
Now when you cut an
onion, how do you not
cry from cutting an onion?
Sharp knife really,
really helps.
Nice job.
A lot of people don't know that.
And you're going to
stay there, Bria,
and make sure we don't burn.
All right?
You can turn it
down if you need to.
Sharp knife helps but--
AUDIENCE: Don't
cut off the root.
JOEL GAMORAN: Don't
cut off the root?
I've never heard
that one before.
There's all these like crazy--
my grandma is like, freeze it.
I'm like, how do you
chop a frozen onion?
I have also heard hold a
match in your left hand.
I'm like, what are
you talking about?
So the right way to
not cry from an onion
is when you chop into an
onion, the gases from the onion
kind of rise to the top.
So they kind of just go
up towards the ceiling,
and they're attracted
to anything wet.
Our eyes are wet.
So if you put a little
wet napkin in your mouth,
you look ridiculous, but it
will be attracted to the napkin
before your eyes and
make a huge difference.
So that's just a little
something something.
Now onion peels, by
the way, delicious.
I make an onion peel batter
fried pickle in the book.
And I've been cooking this
across the country on the book
tour.
People are losing their
minds around onion peels.
You can put them in
your chicken stocks
and then fish them out later.
But onion peels have so much
flavor and they're amazing.
So I got a little onion.
I'm just going to chop this up.
When you chop onion
and you get halfway,
just turn the onion
over so you don't have
to get awkward with your hands.
How we Doing We looking good?
All right.
So we have onion, we've got
garlic, we've got chile.
Everyone in.
Beautiful.
Now big pinch of salt. How
would you salt this, Bria?
That was not a bad
salt. I'm impressed.
So the right way to salt is
three fingers and a thumb,
always.
I like kosher salt
because you can feel it.
And always from up high so
the salt spreads, right?
So that's why you see
chefs do that on TV.
It's not just because we look
cool, although we do look cool.
But it absolutely
makes a difference.
So we've got that
going, smelling amazing.
We're all with me so far.?
So far can everyone
do this at home?
It's not too crazy.
Just add a little
different type of heat,
a little pinch of chile.
Save it from the next
time you order pizza.
That's scrappy.
And then our tomato tops.
Cool?
So I just want to show
you guys what to do.
Let's say you have even
these onion peels or mushroom
bottoms, or anything
that you have
that's not edible but
can give you flavor.
I actually like to wrap
up butternut squash,
like outside, the shell
of butternut squash.
So what you can do is wrap
it up in a little package.
You want to do this, Bria?
So just wrap that up.
This is cheesecloth.
You can buy it Sur la Table.
You can buy it on Amazon.
It's everywhere.
It's cheap as chips.
Wrap it up in a little bundle.
And that way you can throw it
in like a little tea infuser.
I like to call it a flavor bomb.
And it's going to just
kind of enrich everything,
and again, give that tomato
vibe all the way through.
So this looks awesome.
Tomatoes in.
If you ever go to the
market--and I know tomatoes are
just getting out of season--
but ask for seconds.
What are seconds?
Yeah, imperfect.
They're always under the
table at the farmer's market,
even at Whole Foods.
They have these tomatoes that
are busted, they're open,
they can't sell them.
For something like
this or a tomato sauce,
it's genius because they're
bursting with sugar,
they're bursting with juice.
That is prime time tomatoes,
and they'll give it to you
for much, much reduced price.
All right.
So stir that in, my dear.
You got it?
Now we're going to throw
in our flavor bomb.
And them-- yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you
reuse cheesecloth,
or do you throw it away?
JOEL GAMORAN: You can
absolutely reuse it.
Yeah, that's a good question.
Yeah.
I've never done it, but
you can absolutely do it.
I will start reusing
my cheesecloth.
So undisputed King, of
cheeses, Parmesan cheese.
This, a muu muu, and a rom com,
I'm pretty much good for life.
OK?
I will eat this like
a piece of cake.
I love Parmesan cheese, and I
love every bit of the Parmesan
cheese.
But we all throw away
the outside, the rind.
The rind you're starting
to see in specialty stores
now sold separately
from the cheese.
This stuff, just smell it.
This is like--
I just got chills.
This is umame, you guys.
This makes food taste rich.
This makes food taste filling.
This gives it layer.
And so Parmesan cheese just
tossed in with a pot of beans,
or while you're boiling pasta,
or in this case, some soup--
just toss it right in--
unbelievably good.
You can take it out
later, gnaw on it.
You'll be fine.
Or you can fry it
after you use it,
and it gets puffy, like a
chicharon, like a cracker.
Dude, that's where
half of this came from.
OK?
Really, really good.
Give it up for Bria.
Thank you very much.
Thanks, buddy.
So we're going to turn
our heat up, kind of
get these tomatoes going.
And then we don't
add the bread yet.
The bread is going to
happen kind of later.
Another great thing you
can do with this is we're
going to add basil at the end.
And basil stems, and the
stems of a lot of herbs,
hold so much love in them.
So I want to show you
guys a quick little thing.
Who wants to help me
with this next recipe?
Come on up.
Give it up, bro.
I love it.
So I am kind of tired
of the same old,
you know, I got invited
over to someone's house
and I want to bring
over a bottle of wine.
I want to bring over
something different.
I want to bring over something
maybe a little bit out
of the box.
So I'm going to teach you guys
how to make a flavored salt.
OK?
You can put this in a cute
jar, give it away to someone.
But really, this is so
good for your cooking.
So turn this guy up even more.
Let's see.
We've got lemon basil here.
Isn't that right, Elizabeth?
From Google gardens.
You guys grew this.
This is unbelievably good.
So let's say you
have basil at home.
Come on in.
What's your name?
TARIK: Tarik.
JOEL GAMORAN: Tarik.
Good to meet you.
Come on over.
So Tarik, let's say you're at
home, and you had a recipe.
Maybe it was a salad
that called for basil.
So you take it off the stem
and you're left with the stem.
I mean, the m--
put this under a
pillow and you're
going to sleep really well.
I mean, this is
beautifully smell.
But we're going to
use it to make a salt.
So the leaves we'll save
for a different time.
But that's the part that
would always be saved.
And then I've got an old
school pestle and mortar.
So Tarik, what I'm
going to have you do
is I'm going to have
you take these stems.
I'm just going to
kind of chop them up.
And you can do this with
mint stems, parsley stems,
cilantro stems, basil
stems, whatever you got,
I want you to go to town, baby.
Take a little stress out.
Yeah.
TARIK: Yeah, I'm doing it.
JOEL GAMORAN: I know
you're doing it.
Get in there, move it around.
Yeah.
Bend your knees.
Yeah, go, baby.
There you go.
Beautiful.
That's good.
So just so everyone can
see, it's just pulverized.
It's just this paste.
Smells ungodly.
I mean, ungodly.
We could bottle
that and sell it.
Chunky salt. So this is
different than kosher salt.
So you guys can see big,
giant flakes, right?
This is maldon salt, sea
salt. Look for these.
I'm going to add, for every
tablespoon of crushed herbs,
I'm going to add a 1/2 a cup
of salt. It's a lot of salt.
I called your doctors.
You guys will be [INAUDIBLE].
So what I want you to do
now, Tarik, is just keep,
but more kind of rub it.
Go for it, yeah.
Get in there, yeah.
Look at this.
He gets into it.
Really.
He's more passionate than I am.
I love it.
So as he's doing this,
as Tarik's doing this--
and you can kind
of confirm, Tarik--
the salt is turning colors.
The salt is becoming what?
BRIA: Greener.
JOEL GAMORAN: Greener.
And it's picking up all
the oils from those stems.
So now I just want you
guys to be able to see.
Dude, you did amazing.
Let me just feel this.
My god.
Unbelievable.
Look at this.
What was once-- yeah, good save.
What was once
totally trash is now
this stunning, floral, beautiful
salt. And you smell this,
and we'll pass it around.
But this in a jar, this
over a piece of fish, this
to finish a salad, this
as a little garnish
over the top of
the soup, genius.
And such a nice gift.
If you really care
about the stems, Tarik,
you're going to hold this.
I'm going to just hold it
right over that parchment.
You just pour it
in and shake it.
Yep.
And it catches all
the stems for you.
If you really want
like a perfect salt--
I like all the stems,
but totally up to you.
Where's my little bowl?
So I want to pass this around.
Look at this.
Is that awesome?
You can do mint sugar.
You don't have to do
salt. That's perfect.
So just so everyone can see,
you can gather everything up.
In they goes, and the
most beautiful stem cell.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How well
does it store?
JOEL GAMORAN: This
will never go bad,
because none of the
herb that's in here,
it will go dry just
like dry herbs.
So there's nothing in
here that will go bad.
It might lose its flavor
after about two years,
but absolutely beautiful.
Give it up for Tarik.
Nice job.
I'm going to pass this around.
You guys into that recipe?
It's pretty crazy, right?
It's kind of fun.
Any questions so far?
Nothing?
Come on, give me something.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So like
herbs, or onion peels,
those kinds of things?
JOEL GAMORAN: Great question.
Great question.
So the question
was is when you're
cooking at home, what do
you do when you don't know
what to do with this stuff?
You're just trying
to make dinner.
And the last thing you want
to worry about is this.
Right?
Totally agree with that.
So what I do is I always have a
bowl, in this case a glass one.
But I always have a ball
for my scraps on my counter.
Always you're going
to go to the ball
first because it's
right near you,
as opposed you don't want to
have the trash can nearby.
Then I get a piece of paper,
and I kind of do it in half,
and I put it on the bowl.
So I can kind of
divide the ball up
between like savory scraps,
like herbs and onion peels
and things like that.
Maybe there's protein scraps,
things like chicken or beef fat
or those little
things I want to save.
So they kind of stay separate.
Then I cook dinner.
At the end of dinner I put
them in a little Ziploc bags,
and I make best friends
with the freezer, guys.
The freezer is your friend
when it comes to scraps.
The last thing you
should be doing
is thinking about I
gotta use this today.
You totally don't.
That will stay good in the
freezer for six to nine months.
You'll be totally fine.
So just make sure you save them.
And then it's going to be
like a Wednesday night,
and you're going to be
like, what do I cook?
I don't know what to make.
And you're going to
open your freezer
and there's going to be a
treasure trove of things.
So that's kind of the
goal with all this.
Really good question.
Anything else?
Cool.
All right, well, our
tomato is blipping away.
You'll notice I didn't add
any water to this, no chicken
stock.
I just kind of want to
make sure everyone can see.
Isn't that beautiful?
And when tomatoes
aren't in season,
you can absolutely used canned
tomatoes for this recipe.
It will work totally fine.
So we're going to let that hang.
But before we do, we've
got our stale bread.
This is bread soup.
So this is where I
would add my bread.
And normally I would let this
go for like 20 more minutes
and really let those
tomatoes break down.
But just in the interest
of Google time--
you guys have meetings
and places to go--
we're going to put the
bread in and just kind
of let it soak up.
Now, why is it
important, do you guys
think, to season a soup
at the very end, not now?
Like I haven't added
much salt to this.
Why?
AUDIENCE: I think it's because
it evaporates [INAUDIBLE]
JOEL GAMORAN: Bria, nice.
So she nailed it, which is if
you have--I'm just going to do
a little visual aid here.
If you have a soup that
starts off like this,
and when you're cooking, all
of it is starting to cook away.
So it starts off like
this, but at the end
it kind of becomes like this.
It comes to here.
So that salt, let's
say it's perfect here,
won't be perfect when it's here.
It's going to be too salty.
So you always season sauces
and soups and things that
are reducing at the very end.
Otherwise it's going to reduce
and make it totally inedible.
Make sense?
Cool?
All right.
Ready for the next
piece of magic?
I-- for as classy as
you may think I am,
which I am not at all--
I have a little
trashy side to me.
I love me some ranch dressing.
Any ranch lovers in the house?
Thank you for admitting it.
Yes.
He was like, yes, I like ranch.
I could bathe in ranch.
I'm sorry.
I love ranch.
But ranch dressing you
usually buy in a bottle.
It's really creamy.
It's really bad for you.
So I wanted to make
a ranch dressing
that had no cream that was
actually somewhat good for you.
And the basis of
this ranch dressing
is a scrap that I
absolutely love.
So who wants to help me
with our ranch dressing?
Someone's got to come up here.
Yeah, give it up for him.
What's your name?
STEVEN: Steven.
JOEL GAMORAN: Steven.
Good he meet you.
Joel.
All right, So aqua faba.
What the heck is aqua faba?
Have you ever heard
the word before?
I'll give you an air high five.
Yes, nice.
Bean water is what aqua faba is.
So what I mean by
bean watered is
let's say you cook
a big pot of beans.
It's the water left in the pot.
Let's say you open a jar of
beans, like most of us do.
It's the water inside the jar.
So you said your name's
Steven, is that right?
So come on over here, Steven.
So we're going to open up.
We've got some chickpeas here.
I just want you to hold
the lid back and just pour
the liquid right in there.
So if you look at the liquid
that Steven's pouring--
that's perfect.
That's great.
It kind of looks
like egg whites.
It's kind of thick.
Raise your hand if you've
ever drained chickpeas,
beans over the sink and it
just goes down the drain,
all the stuff.
I told you.
It's like Scraps
Anonymous in here.
We have all done it.
We've all done it.
But we're going to change that
because this right here not
only can make creamy dressings,
it can become meringue.
There's marinades
you can do with this.
You can thicken soups with this.
There's so much you can do.
So we're going to
turn it, though,
into my favorite little ranch.
So you're going to grab a
little immersion blender.
Does everyone have one of these?
If you don't, you can
absolutely just use a blender
or do it by hand, but it's a
lot easier with one of these.
All right.
So stick it right in there.
Yep, and then press that button.
STEVEN: Low or high?
JOEL GAMORAN: Yep.
And in, like, I don't know,
five seconds, look at the color.
It goes from kind of
like that egg whitey
to like this creamy,
gorgeous, light, cloudy color.
Does that look awesome?
All right, so we'll pause there.
Good.
Then what we got is a bunch
of spices, normal ranch stuff.
So garlic powder, dried oregano.
Go for it.
STEVEN: Put this in?
JOEL GAMORAN: All
of it in, baby, yep.
And you can take the one
in from underneath of it.
Yeah, I hid it.
I got a little black pepper, a
little dried thyme, right in,
go with the black pepper.
A little bit of salt and sugar.
I mean, this is all stuff
that's just in your cupboard.
Garlic, fresh garlic.
And then this is
apple cider vinegar.
So blitz that up, my friend.
And already you just look
at it, it's like, oh my god,
it's ranch dressing.
Like it's happening right
here before your eyes.
Look at the color.
It's got the little flecks.
It's got everything.
I love testing this recipe.
I tested it like 10 times.
OK.
Wrong thing.
Cool.
So make sure this guy's on.
Good.
There you go.
OK.
So we're nice and
creamy, frothy there.
Next thing we're going to do
is we're going to add lemon.
Whenever you guys have a lemon,
and let's say it's really hard,
you can absolutely microwave
it for about 20 seconds,
and the juices will just
come flowing out of it.
But if you have a nice,
soft lemon like this,
best thing to do is roll
on it before you chop it
and the juices will
really get loosened up.
Now we're going to zest this.
You've got a micro
plane right here.
Got it right under here.
There you go, my friend.
Do you know to zest a lemon?
Show me how you do it.
It's a trick.
No, I'm kidding.
So what you do is-- no problem.
The best way to zest
a lemon is pretend
like you're giving
someone low five.
Put the micro
plane in your hand.
Kind of stick it on the
board, and then on it.
And you always turn the lemon
or the orange to a new spot,
meaning it's not like cheese
where you go like this.
You do one strike,
and then a new spot.
That way it doesn't get
bitter, and you always
kind of get the same thing.
So you want to get
me a little bit more?
Go for it.
Oh, this soup is looking insane.
Unreal.
That looks great.
That's plenty.
Use this bad boy.
Love it.
That goes right in there.
Beautiful.
That's OK.
And zip it up.
While he's doing that, I'm
going to grab a little bit
of the lemon juice.
Always through your fingers.
This is like a sieve.
Beautiful.
And then I'm going
to grab some oil.
And this is like vegetable oil.
This is not olive oil.
Olive oil, for things like
this, it's too strong.
You'll taste oil
instead of tasting
all the flavor you put into it.
So we're going to
start nice and slow.
And then you're going to go big.
Is this crazy or what?
I mean, seriously, I think it's
one of the coolest recipes.
You guys are about to try it.
You can kind of
hear it changing.
It's going from soft to thick.
You guys hear that?
That means you're
doing it right.
This will stay good in
the fridge for a week.
And it will stay good in the
freezer for about three months.
That looks great.
Done.
Give it up for Steven.
Nice job, buddy.
Watch the glass on your way out.
Beautiful.
I'm going to pick up this jar.
OK.
Me doing a demo where
I break only one
thing is a big plus for me.
That's a big step up.
So what I like to do
is grab this dressing.
And just so everyone can
see, I've got a plate here.
And I like to just
kind of pour it out.
Look at the texture.
I mean, that's ranch, right?
I mean, it's creamy.
It's light.
When you put this in the fridge,
you absolutely will have--
it will get a little thicker and
a little bit more easy to dip.
So we've got some crudites here.
I wanted to show you
guys a couple of tricks.
First of all, cauliflower, man.
This stuff at the grocery store,
these leaves are unbelievable.
They're like bok choy.
You guys can throw
them in stir fries.
You can put them in soups.
They're so delicious.
But cauliflower like this,
take all these leaves off.
And again, if you're in
the middle of a recipe,
don't worry about them.
Just freeze them.
You'll come back to them.
They're not going anywhere.
And then something like
this, these Romanescos,
Just kind of in
half, and then just
kind of cut off the outsides.
The actual stem itself,
absolutely delicious to put
in soups and things like that.
But I like to just kind of make
a little pile in the ranch.
This is like fancy ranch.
I've got some carrots.
No big deal.
I like to wash them
and leave the skins on.
Totally OK to do.
But I'm kind of just making
a little crudite plate.
When I plate things I
try and get it high so
it kind of goes
into someone's face.
That always kind of makes it
a little bit more inviting.
It's one of the first things
they kind of teach you
at culinary school.
So nice big pile of veggies.
We have kind of the ranch
dressing on the bottom.
Then tomatoes.
I love this next trick.
So cutting cherry tomatoes
is a total pain in the butt.
Sucks.
Cutting grapes is
a pain in the butt.
Cutting olives is
a pain in the butt
because you have
to go one by one.
So I don't know if anyone's
ever seen this trick,
but you take two
deli containers,
take a handful of them.
Right on.
Cool.
Then other one over the top.
Grab a serrated knife.
And right through.
And you have chopped in
half cherry tomatoes.
Give it up for that trick.
I love that trick.
Did that just change your lives?
That totally changed your lives.
So a little bit of chopped
cherry tomatoes, and then
pepper.
Also kind of a pain
in the butt to chop.
And one of the biggest things we
talk about on the cooking show
and also in the book
is how food looks.
And a pepper--
I don't know if you
guys know this, but see
how this pepper stands up?
I just learned there's a
company here in the Bay
called Imperfect Produce.
Has anyone ever
worked with them?
They're awesome.
Yeah, they're really cool.
Yeah, so Imperfect Produce
saves food that would normally
get rejected by grocery stores.
So a pepper, if it
falls over like this
and it won't stand
up, it won't be sold.
It goes in the trash
because grocery stores
need it to have symmetry so
they can stack it up high, which
is just ridiculous.
It's absolutely crazy.
And so we have to
get around this idea
that food needs to look perfect.
It should look imperfect, just
like we all look imperfect,
and we should celebrate
it for what it is.
So a good way to cut a pepper
is top off, bottom off.
You can save this stuff
for kind of something else.
And then I take my
knife and I roll it.
And you have this beautiful
kind of sheet of pepper,
really easy to
chop with no seeds.
This, unfortunately, is cooking
crappy, not cooking scrappy,
so this is not good.
So don't save that.
That can go to the chickens.
And then I just
kind of cut this up,
and I've got this beautiful
kind of veggie platter
in like, what, five minutes,
with gorgeous Romanescos,
homemade ranch, all with kind
of things made from food waste.
So give it up for
this dish right here.
Love that one.
So we've got our
kind of appetizer.
Let's revisit our soup.
And just want everyone
to be able to see.
It's been what, I don't
know, 15 minutes, 20 minutes
with the soup cooking down.
So I just want everyone
to kind of look inside.
The whole soup has transformed.
I mean, it's really thick
now because of the bread.
It's absolutely beautiful.
So what we're going to do
is just plate this guy up.
So I'm going to grab a plate.
And the last step to
this, really, really easy.
I grab like a ladle or two
of the actual soup, put it
in a bowl.
Then I grab a little blender
and just kind of blitz this up.
And this makes it really smooth.
You can do this with-- whoops,
it's going to be a mess.
Always is.
But if you guys can see the
texture difference-- light,
creamy--
and then you kind
of bring it back in.
And it kind of, I
don't know, marbles
throughout, gives it
a different texture.
So some of it is creamy, some
of it is a little chunky,
and I love that.
The Parmesan rinds themselves,
try and fish them out.
But if someone gets it in their
bowl don't worry about it.
It's not the end of the world.
Yeah, exactly.
They'll love it.
And then just a nice
serving of this.
And you can see, this is thick.
You know, this dish
was a pleasant dish
because stale bread,
back in Italy,
everyone had stale bread.
So it was kind of thought
of as a low class dish,
but it's so beautiful.
It's so, I don't know,
vibrant and filling.
I'm going to grab a little bit
of that parm, which I am all
over the place with the parm.
Where's my parm?
Thanks, buddy.
So a little bit that
parm right over the top.
Doesn't that look good?
You guys are going to be
able to try this, trust me.
Little basil on top.
I mean, that's homemade
tomato soup 101,
but with celebrating
stale bread.
I mean, really the
centerpiece of this dish.
So you can take a little bit
of basil right over there,
maybe our basil salt
right over the top.
Fit for a king.
Give it up for that
dish right there.
So we've got scraps
all over the place.
I've got soup.
I broke something.
We had a real party here.
But any questions
about any of this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that salt
enough for the soup?
JOEL GAMORAN: What's that?
The salt?
Yeah, absolutely.
Just a little
finishing salt. Yeah,
because the Parmesan rind
gives it a lot of saltiness.
And then you'll remember
in the beginning,
we salted just a little bit.
So it will get there.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Good question.
What else?
AUDIENCE: So I've
got a question.
You demo'd probably three of one
of your more favorite recipes.
Or what are the top two or
three, when they open this book
and they go home, that
you are the most proud
of because there's a
personal connection,
it's more innovative.
What are some of the things?
I mean, I think that the aqua
faba ranch was super cool.
I'm going to try that for sure.
What are the other recipes that
you're like, go here first?
JOEL GAMORAN: OK.
So anyone ever have
brown bananas at home?
So those brown bananas
come in a peel.
So in the book is a
brown banana and peel
cake with whipped
peanut butter frosting.
This thing is transformational.
It's like religion.
It is so good.
Banana peels kind of
tastes like plums.
And when you think about bananas
and when they turn brown,
that's the color of caramel.
That's sugar.
So that just means they're
sweeter bananas, so not worth
throwing away.
So that's one.
And I would say I came
up with this thing called
the sea salt, which is like
a BLT but with chicken skin.
So it's chicken skin,
avocado, lettuce and tomato.
And you bake the chicken skin,
so you take it off the chicken
and you bake it.
And it gets so crispy,
and it is insane.
I come from a Jewish household.
My dad can't eat bacon,
and I made it for him,
and he was like done for life.
He loved it.
Those are my two.
Very cool.
Any questions?
Yes.
Let me pass you the mic.
AUDIENCE: That bean water.
Does it matter what type
of peas or beans you use?
JOEL GAMORAN: Absolutely not.
AUDIENCE: Would it be
black beans or kidney
beans where it's like the
water is redder or darker?
JOEL GAMORAN: Right.
So the only thing I
would say is black beans
are a little tough for it.
So black beans just
make a crazy color.
But it works with black beans.
I've done it.
Works with red beans.
So any beans.
But if you want to make a
kind of a creamy texture,
it's definitely a white bean.
Yeah, good question.
What else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You talked about the
freezer being your best friend.
What's your take on refreezing?
I mean, once you've already
taken it out and it's thawed,
where do you draw the line
in terms of refreezing?
JOEL GAMORAN: Proteins
is where I draw the line.
So the question is
is can you refreeze?
Once you freeze something,
you take it out,
can you put it back
in the freezer?
If it's a protein like fish skin
or chicken bones or pork fat,
once it's out, it's out
and you've got to use it.
But vegetables and fruit
scraps, absolutely.
You can always refreeze.
Yeah, good question.
What else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
You mentioned that the
middle of the bell pepper
was inedible at some point.
Somewhere in your book
or online, et cetera,
is there a place where we can
find out like oh, this actually
I shouldn't eat, like,
to not be poisoned?
JOEL GAMORAN: Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
So I don't have a full list,
although that is a genius idea.
So I might put that together.
You could absolutely Google it.
There's a great website.
But no, I don't know
if there's anything
that I would say, particularly,
that if I have a list of things
you can't eat.
I will say that in the
very beginning of our chat
we talked about our
grandparents, or maybe
other generations.
They were, back then, really
trusting their senses.
And so I have a whole
chapter in the book called--
and like I said, cooking
scrappy, not cooking crappy.
That means if chicken
smells off, throw it away.
If there's fuzz on the outside
of a strawberry, throw it away.
That stuff's not worth it.
But we know what
that looks like.
We know what that smells like.
What I'm asking you guys to do
is look at the whole picture.
One thing that a
lot of people ask
me about is about expiration
dates, and are they real?
And do you throw your milk
away the second the date hits?
So we just did a whole
episode about this.
And expiration dates
and sell by dates,
they're totally dictated
by the manufacturer.
So they're all over the place.
So it goes back to,
again, open up the milk.
Even if it's a week past its
date, smell it, pour it out.
I'm sure it will be fine.
But you will know.
If you have doubt, throw it away
and don't feel bad about it.
Yeah, good question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I really
like that salt recipe,
but it doesn't use
a lot of herb stems.
You have a lot of recipes
that use a lot of herb stems.
JOEL GAMORAN: Oh, man, yes.
Absolutely I have a whole
herb stem sauce in there where
you use the entire herb stem.
If you use a ton of
them, like let's say
you picked a whole
bunch of parsley,
you can use them as a
bed to bake fish on.
And they actually cook down
in the juices of the fish
and elevate the fish at
the bottom of the pan.
So they kind of act as like
a little rack, which I love.
So herb stems are unbelievable.
And of course you
could throw them
in your stocks and your
soups and things like that.
Yeah, absolutely.
What else?
AUDIENCE: I think
another thing that
sort of goes to waste
in my personal kitchen
are like condiments.
Like you buy a sauce for
a one time use and then
you just don't really
ever use it again.
In your experience, have
you ever combined condiments
to make a new sauce?
JOEL GAMORAN: Totally.
Totally, yes.
So airing tonight on FYI Network
is a Scrappy Thanksgiving
Special.
It's one hour special where
we take all the leftovers
from Thanksgiving, and we whip
up a whole weekend's worth
of food.
And if you can't
catch it tonight,
you can watch it on
Saturday morning, too.
But we do this exact thing.
It's all about condiments.
How do you make the most
of them in your fridge?
What do you do with
your mayo, your ketchup?
How can you
repurpose everything?
So the idea is instead of
going out after Thanksgiving,
or after any meal,
look in the fridge.
I have a hashtag on
Instagram if anyone wants it.
You take a picture
of your fridge,
open it up, and say scrap
my fridge at Joel Gamoran,
and I will respond with a video
of what you should make out
of your fridge.
And I respond to them all,
which seemed like a mistake
in the beginning, but
now I really like it.
So if you guys don't
know what to make,
you can always call on me.
AUDIENCE: I want to
build on what you just
said because the chefs at Google
do a very similar approach.
We traditionally
are always looking
to create menus based off
what the chef's excited about.
And if you flip
the whole paradigm
and go hey, Mr. or Mrs.
Farmer, what do you have,
it's the same exact opportunity.
So when I go home and cook, my
wife's like, what's for dinner,
I'm like, I don't know,
and we open the fridge.
And it's exactly
that opportunity.
So raise of hands.
How many people here
have actually taken
that approach, whether you're
a confident cook or not,
to actually look in the
cupboard, look in the pantry,
to your point, look
at the condiments,
and actually experiment?
Raise of hands.
Who's tried it?
I would challenge everyone
here to make that opportunity,
because there's
no right or wrong.
You're either going
to like it or not.
If you don't like it, make
it taste better or just
keep working on it.
But it's a really good point.
I love that.
JOEL GAMORAN: And I'm
so glad you guys do that
here at Google.
I'm not surprised at all
because you guys are always
on the forefront of it.
But the reality is is that
everyone always asks me, well,
what's an action item that
I can take away after I
teach a little class like this?
What is one thing I can do?
The one thing I
say you could do is
replace one day of cooking
out with staying in and trying
to make the most
of what you have.
And if you just do that
once, it will be huge.
So to Chef Scott's point,
push yourselves a little bit.
It will make a big difference.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are there
things you recommend
we keep in our pantry or kitchen
in generally to enable that?
JOEL GAMORAN: Just to
always have on hand?
That's a tough question.
That's a really,
really tough question.
My pantry I invest a lot in.
But I only shop my
pantry probably once
every three months.
So I always have my flours, my
nut oils, my seasoning blends,
all that stuff.
I do that like probably
four times a year
and I go groceries
shopping for that.
What I do every week
is for my proteins
and my fruits and my
vegetables, those turn out.
I always have carrots, celery,
and onions, always, always,
always, always.
I always have chicken
and neutral meats.
And then I'm a big believer
in cooking on Sundays
and then really trying
to stretch it out
until Thursday, Friday,
and seeing if you can't
do a little meal prepping.
So I'm huge on that.
Yeah.
Good question.
SCOTT: Huge round of applause.
Absolutely.
This is one of
the most fun talks
that I've had the opportunity
to host because it's something
that everyone should
have fun with.
And it's a new discipline to
actually take home and actually
see what are we
actually throwing away.
I mean, going to what
you said earlier,
between 40 if not more
percent of the world's food
is essentially wasted.
It doesn't make it
from the farm to us,
or when it makes it to our
house, it doesn't get cooked.
And it's a travesty.
And to eliminate that, or at
least help with that, let alone
look at all these
opportunities to serve
the skins and the peels and
the tops, super, super cool.
So a couple more questions, and
then we're going to wrap it up.
Any final questions
from the team here?
Or do you have any
questions for us?
JOEL GAMORAN: Yes,
I have a question.
I'd like to play a
game if you guys want
to play a game with me.
It's called Stump the Scrap.
So I like to call
out a scrap, and I'd
like to see what you
guys would make with it.
Cool?
All right.
What would you do with
butternut squash seeds?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Roast them,
salt them, season them,
enjoy them as a great snack.
JOEL GAMORAN: Exactly, baby.
Roast them, season them.
Give it up, I love
it, for Tarik.
OK.
What would you do with--
like you buy a steak and there's
a lot of fat on the outside,
so you cut it off.
What would you do
with that beef fat?
AUDIENCE: Render it and
make some kind of confit.
JOEL GAMORAN: Damn, dude.
I love it.
Give it up.
That's amazing.
So he said render it and
make some sort of confit.
So rendering fat, if
you have extra fat,
you can put it in a pan
with a little drop of water
and cook it really
slow for 30 minutes.
And it will turn
into like an oil.
And now you have
this beef fat oil.
You toss your potatoes in that.
You cook your omelet in that.
It is so, so good.
So yes, rendering
it out is great.
All right.
One more.
Do we have time for one more?
SCOTT: One more, yeah.
JOEL GAMORAN: What
would you do with--
it's got to be a good one.
Oh, I'll stump you on this one.
What would you do
with peach pits?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOEL GAMORAN: I'm shocked
that you actually got that.
Nice job.
Give it up.
So what she said
was-- very nice--
is you can infuse it.
So peach pits taste like
almonds when you infuse it.
So if you put it
in vodka, you can
make this peach pit beautiful
vodka that you can make drinks
with, or a simple syrup.
You can make a really good,
kind of almondy flavored
simple syrup.
But you said soak it in milk.
You can make peach pit ice
cream, peach pit panna cotta.
Lots of different things.
So even look at those pits.
They're worth it.
SCOTT: Awesome job.
Let's give Joel Gamoran
a huge round of applause.
"Cooking Scrappy," and
we'll see it on YouTube.
Thanks again.
JOEL GAMORAN: Thank you.